So good morning. Uh, I bring you
news from Nashville, Nashville.
Um, very interesting. Nashville,
it's such an interesting weekend.
Friday night went to this spectacular
concert of Mozart doing the Mozart requiem
in this $135 million concert hall that
they have put built for classical music
in the city of Nashville. The next
afternoon, Saturday afternoon,
I walked across the street. I could've
have gone two blocks to watch it.
I'm a hockey game.
They have a hockey team in Nashville or
three blocks in the other direction to
watch the titans play in football,
stand by one,
just one block to the
country music hall of fame.
So I spent three hours in the country
music hall of fame and absolutely
fascinated,
but it got even better because Sunday
morning there I was at the airport about
to fly out of Nashville and I'm sitting
there and you know how you were queuing
up to get and go out your gate to
get on your airplane and you're,
they've CNN is playing on the television
there. It was wonderful. What did I hear?
Okay.
Oh, Mozart, Mozart right
here in the airport.
In Nashville and then
we had one on from that.
There was another commercial and they used
and so on. I do. One of us does
strange, wonderful war. What a strange,
wonderful country to have
such diversity ethnically,
politically, uh, and musically. Uh,
and at the same time to have a sense
that there's this little person who was
only about five feet,
three inches tall,
probably weighed about 110 pounds.
Sitting in a room in Vienna,
Austria,
more than 200 years ago could
create this beauty that we still,
um,
engaged today,
whether consciously or subconsciously
when we're sitting in an airport in
Nashville, Tennessee,
right? Astonishing. What,
what the brain sometimes experiences.
Well,
today we're going to talk about Mozart.
Now the Muse music that you just heard.
Let's play just a little of it. Linda.
Let's start with a,
it should be tracked and there the
little g minor symphony of Mozart.
Let's just play it a little bit of it.
Okay.
Let's just stop it there. And we're going
to come back to this in just a second.
It's music of the classical period.
It's music of Mozart.
It happens to me what's called little g
minor symphony and contrast that to the
music that you heard in
section last week by Bach
and so on where he gets a concerto
going. Dot. T, t, t, t, t, t, t, t, t,
t, t, t, t, t, t, t, t,
and it sort of chugs along in that same
fashion chosen along in fact for about
nine minutes and 20 seconds,
all with the music having the same
general tenor, the same general mood,
the same general feeling to it.
That's baroque music.
Once you get an ethos
established in baroque music,
it will carry through from beginning
to end of a particular movement or a
particular piece. It doesn't
change. Uh, generally speaking,
when we get to the classical
period, however, and we're here,
we're talking roughly 1750
up to around 1820 or so,
things get a little bit different. We
get change within a particular movement.
Change might be from regular to irregular.
Rhythm for example,
are from very loud too.
Two very quiet. And this,
this push for change only accelerates
as we go into the romantic period where
you get these wild swings of emotion,
these wild swings of musical mood to
kind of bipolar music in the 19th century
when this begins in the classical period.
So let's go back and hear the beginning
of this symphony number 25 in g minor of
Mozart. And notice here we begin minor
key, lots of syncopation agitation.
And within about 40 seconds,
Mozart has morphed into a
completely different mood.
Major key oboe solo.
Uh,
the music is very lyrical. Uh,
the meter now is co or the,
the rhythms are all lined up to come
on the beat rather than off the beat.
Watch how we had this transformation
of mood within a rather short period of
time.
Okay.
Completely different sort of music.
Now that sound that you just heard
there is the opening music for the film
Amadeus. How many have seen the movie or
film Amadeus? If you haven't go see it.
It's just not to be believed.
It is so good.
And it doesn't age either because
it's all done in period costumes.
So you don't know that
anything has really changed.
It's a wonderful movie is
based on two premises. One,
what does mediocrity do in the
face of absolute genius and to,
isn't that ironic?
Isn't it somehow unfair
that this God given talent,
this great creature comes to earth in
the form of this sort of childish lout I.
E. Mozart. Uh, uh, and it, we'll
explore that just to just a little bit.
And how does someone like Peter Schaeffer
who created the play and on which was
built the, uh, the film Emma Days, how did
they create a character like this? Well,
they use memoirs of the time,
letters of the time,
primary source documents of the time.
You may remember in Amadeus,
and I put a picture of this
and the textbook because I
think it's actually very
important trying to get
inside of Mozart's head
that Mozart often composed on a
billiard table billiard table.
That's what we see in Amadeus. Is
this true? Yes, it is actually true.
If you look at the probate list of Mozart,
uh,
they went through his apartment
after he died in the inventory,
all the furniture and said where
everything was in his bedroom.
He had a billiards table, not a
pool table, but a billiards table.
There's an important difference here
because billiards of course involves, uh,
angles m and a. There is a report
from one of, of Mozart's friends,
a tender micro Kelly who
said in his memoirs quote,
he was fond of billiards and had an
excellent billiard table in his home.
Many and many a game I played with him,
but always came off second best.
Um,
and Mozart had other interests to his,
one of his other interests was arithmetic.
And if you look at the Mozart autographs,
uh,
and particularly the Mozart sketches,
you will see that he fills the margins
oftentimes with numbers doing various
basic calculations and sometimes
some fundamental Algebraic, uh,
formulations.
Why this fascination with
numbers and shapes and patterns.
He would go into a restaurant. He would
be seen folding his napkin this way,
this way, this way,
when he writes letters,
he oftentimes writes the word
backwards. He loves anagrams. Um,
and, and I could give you lots
of specific instances of that.
Another aspect of this is Mozart.
The mimic.
Mozart had an incredible capacity
to imitate other individuals,
their facial gestures there,
their dialects. We can't,
don't have time to go into
it. There's dialects. Um,
and he was fluent learn languages.
Lickety split fluent Italian,
fluent French, fluent English. Of course,
in addition to his, his, uh, native,
uh,
German and he had a great musical memory.
He could retain all of
this sound famous story.
He goes into Sistine Chapel in Rome.
We saw pictures of that two weeks ago.
He hears one piece that couldn't
be performed anywhere else. Uh,
it had never been published, only supposed
to be performed in the paypal chapel.
He goes in once,
here's it walks back to his hotel and
writes the whole thing down. Well,
what is all of this? Uh, well, it's
the capacity, I suppose. What, what,
what is, what is, uh, uh, um,
uh, what is the brain doing
up there? We've got this,
this Oregon probably the least understood.
And we have these various parts of
the brain sound processing for music,
sound processing for the
line, for languages happening
most in the temporal lobe,
but engaging various kinds of,
of near term and longterm memory in
the frontal lobe and probably in the
hippocampus as well.
If you have absolute pitch,
sometimes you short circuit,
apparently this whole process because
that's being recognized, uh, in, in the,
uh, in the brain stem and so on. Um,
so there's lots going on here and
I've given you this sheet, uh,
in which w a Yale neuroscientist,
uh,
David Ross a couple of years ago,
he was the basis of an article in the
Yale Alumni magazine is your brain in
tune,
uh,
and it talks about things such as the
incidents of absolute pitch in this world.
Uh, roughly one person
in every 10,000, uh,
has it. So these are the, these are the
kinds of things that interest about us,
about Mozart. Oddly, we can,
we know more about Mozart
than we know about Picasso.
Picasso lived in great artists,
great genius here in the 20th century,
died about 1971 [inaudible] 70.
[inaudible] but we can get inside of
Mozart's head more intentionally and when
know more about him.
And we can't about Picasso because
Mozart left us a tongue of letters.
I just grabbed something.
It was in my bookshelf in my office.
Here's volume two of a five
volume set of letters by Mozart.
So he was always writing letters
to him principally to his father.
And it's on the basis of this kind of
thing that we get a sense of who Mozart
was. Um, the, the portrayal
of Mozart and Emma Dios says,
I say is just absolutely
wrong. It couldn't be more
wrong. The movie is brilliant,
the premise is brilliant,
but the portrayal of Mozart couldn't,
couldn't be more off the
track. A, here's just one,
a letter from those in the
collected letters of Mozart
that always interests me.
It's writing to his father's 1781 about
the time the death of one of his good
friends friend was named
count von hots failed.
And this is what Mozart says about death.
Death is the true goal of our lives.
And I have made myself so eloquent with
it during the past two years that I see
it as the true and best friend of mankind.
Indeed,
the idea of it no longer
holds any terror for me,
but rather much that is tranquil and
comforting and I thank God that he has
granted me the good fortune to obtain
the opportunity of regarding death as the
key to our true happiness.
I never retire at night without
considering that as young as I am.
Perhaps I may be no more on the moral yet.
Not One of those who know me could say
that I am more rows or melancholy and for
this I thank my create her daily and wish
hardly the same happiness may be given
to my fellow man.
I clearly explained my way of looking at
the matter on the occasion of the death
of my very dear best friend count von
hots felt he was just 31 like myself.
I do not grieve for him,
but from the bottom of my heart,
for myself and for all who knew
him as well as I end quote now,
ironically at age 31,
how many more years did Mozart
himself have the live yeah, for he,
he did not make it to 36.
He wrote this stuff,
you'd go in our music library over there
and you could extend your hands like
this and you would not be
able to encompass all of
the music that's been edited
by Mozart. Uh, and he did all of
that. Uh, by the time he was, uh,
uh, was 36. So Mozart's, it's
an interesting character.
Uh, he may have had no formal education,
didn't spend a minute in school.
Why not?
Well,
they didn't have mandatory
education that period.
He was recognized very early on to be
a musical genius. And his father, uh,
nourished him at home, took
them all around the world
to showcase these talents.
Uh, and as he was sort of educated as a
person in the world and his father did
teaching many, many things as,
as he went, went through life.
Um, okay. So what kind of
music did Mozart, right,
what's special about Mozart's music?
Well,
let me try to encapsulate this in a
simple way by saying let's focus on four
things that are peculiar about
Mozart's music or, um, uh,
individual about Mozart's music.
The first,
I would say this infallible sense of
balance and proportion and fallible sense
of balance and proportion.
Yes,
we are in the classical period in the
history of music and that's why we call it
the classical period because
everything does seem to be imbalanced.
There's not an excessive
degree of ornamentation.
The way you find that sometimes in,
in Baroque art for example,
everything is balanced and it,
it is still the norm. Today.
I was dumbfounded looking at that
new concert hall in Nashville.
What did they do? Say it's a knock off
of the u s treasury building or the, the,
uh, Federal Reserve building
in Washington DC. You know,
the basic pedimento them up there,
the columns and all of this.
That's classical architecture. Everything
in perfect balance. Well, in music,
we begin to get this for the first
time here in the classical period.
Remember when we were studying measures
and bars and phrases and I would have
you count measures and invariably we
would find that things are two plus two
four plus four eight plus eight and
that kind of thing. Very symmetrical.
Well this comes into music here for the
first time in a big way in the classical
period. So let's just refresh our memory
here. Here is the Ra of wake case up.
Hey Tay by Mozart,
which we had Lauren liberal sing for us,
but just the beginning of us have it
to get a sense in our ears. Once again,
what's a an antecedent
and consequent phrase,
antecedent
consequence,
antecedent.
Oh it up.
And then shirts
the consequence.
Okay,
we'll just stop it right there.
But everything in four plus four you
can go right to the entire Aria and it's
organized that way. All
right, so that's one point.
One balance shaping perfect proportion
point to the capacity to make something
very beautiful out of the
simplest of materials.
It's sort of oxy moron here with Mozart.
The group is sometimes the simpler
it is, the more beautiful it is. A,
here is the piece they were playing
in the airport in Nashville.
It's out of a piano concerto of Mozart.
It's the one in c major that's
listed on your sheet there.
It's called the Elvira Maddigan concerto
because few years ago they used it as
background,
uh,
music for a movie that we're film that
was based on a novel of Thomas Hardy.
Is that right? Elvira Madigan? I
think that's correct. In any event,
here's the music.
And so I'm going to just stop there
for a second. Let's look at this.
What's that?
Nobody yell it out nicely.
Wow.
Daniel May Daniels has major try it.
Absolutely right.
So he's just ornamenting it a little bit.
Now what's this?
Just to scale, he's up on the
fifth five, four, three, two.
He makes a little more
interesting by doing this.
A little chromaticism inserted there.
So the best stuff we talked about,
the beginning of the class, try
Ed goes up, comes down to scale.
It fills in the triad coming down
the scale. Chromatic inflection.
Next phrase
gets back to the opening idea.
But how's he do that?
This is an interesting chord and we
should focus on it just for a minute.
It's called a dominant seventh chord.
Here's our basic c major triad,
CEG Ya Todd Hall,
and it's made up of two thirds.
If we put one more third up there,
Yattaw Tom Paul,
that would get us up to a seventh chord.
Why is it called a seventh chord? Again?
Because it spans seven
letter names, CDE. She a B,
so total of seven letter names up there,
but it's,
it's simply a triad with another third,
uh,
thrown up there on top.
So we get that idea
back to the tonic
diminished chord.
And so us a little trill at the
end and that's it. It's very,
very simple material,
but it's so beautiful.
And so last thing that you can hear it
once again in the airport in Nashville.
All right,
0.3 0.3 what I would say,
our wild swings of mood with Mozart,
uh,
it begins to come in as mentioned
in the classical period.
This change of mood within a
single composition composition.
But with Mozart is particularly intense
because he likes to swing really quickly
between major and minor keys.
And he likes to go between diatonic
chromatic really quickly and likes to play
off different dynamic levels,
loud and soft.
And that's the essence of
drama, right? Contrast conflict.
That's where we get drama.
So let's listen to a bit of the Kung
Fu totties out of the requiem mass.
We talked a bit about
this a little bit before,
but it wouldn't hurt to hear it again.
So we're gonna start here down low and
demon land in minor agitation and then
we'll shift up into the
higher heavenly realm.
Oops,
what was that?
Yeah, you had it as a listening exercise.
But while Linda goes for, for that, uh,
that, uh, that particular, uh, uh,
tracked or do I haven't not
marked correctly there. Ally, uh,
run, take a look at the CD there.
Um, or it should be on the,
the uh, um, yeah,
I think it's true. It should be track
11 or so down there. What's it say?
It says 10 and what it is at 11,
I incorrectly marked at my fault.
It's track 11 rather than 10.
So here and that was the big g minor
symphony of Mozart. Uh, that was,
that was inadvertently played here.
Now we're going to go to the con
Futon [inaudible] out of the DC,
right of the requiem,
mass
[inaudible]
completely new environment
and then back to the original.
So that's 0.3, strong contrast and
sometimes rather abrupt contracts.
And here's the fourth and final point.
Inexhaustible melodic supply.
Fake community of imagination.
When it comes to melody,
this is an interesting thing.
It's something I'm studying
in my own work at the moment,
looking at a lot of Mozart's
sketches and Mozart.
Sometimes we'd have to sketch something.
He'd sometimes getting a little bit of
trouble and have to write something.
For the most part he had to all in his
head. He's just writing it down. Uh,
but sometimes he did have to sketch
things when he gets in trouble,
has to sketch. It's contrapuntal
issues. Contrapuntal issues,
never melody.
Now you're looking at Beethoven sketches
in the Beethoven sketchbooks and
Beethoven.
We'll wrestle with trying to craft or
get this melody exactly the way he wants
it over and over again.
A ratio after a ratio.
When you look at the Beethoven section of
the textbook there, there's a, uh, a, um,
a facsimile of out of the bay,
the second movement of the Beethoven
Fifth Symphony. Notice all the erasers.
They're in constant corrections.
It took him about 20 years before.
He was happy with
worked
on that theme for a long,
long time before he got exact.
That would never happen with Mozart.
This just flowed perfectly.
Now we're going to play an example here.
I've never used this in any
kind of public forum before.
I'd be interested to see
how it comes across. Uh,
it's an example of Mozart writing
church music for a soprano Solo.
Actually the soprano that had to sing it
was his wife, so she was pretty good. Um,
so let's just listen to
a chunk out of a mass,
the c minor mass by Mozart and see this
sense of melody that just as perfect and
just kind of go on. I'm perfectly
shaped, perfectly proportion,
but you don't have a sense
that he's struggling with
this. It just seems so easy.
Oh,
okay.
Uh, so it should be, uh, uh, track, uh, 11
there are,
I believe that's it.
Hi.
Ooh,
just
positive.
We're just breaking into the middle of it.
This guy could go on forever with it,
with this kind of thing and
sometimes you've got him in trouble.
Sometimes it got him in trouble.
Uh,
what I mean by that is that
there are two famous, uh,
anecdotes coming from Mozart's life.
One at the time of the production
of the induction, the Seraglio,
the emperor's there,
and amber says all well and good
[inaudible] my dear friend Mozart. Um,
but uh,
far too many notes in Mozart's
repose a response was, uh,
uh,
not one nor no more or less than
absolutely necessary your majesty.
Then at the end of the performance,
the first Viennese performance
of Don Giovanni, uh, the emperor,
same emperor Joseph the second said,
too much meat for the teeth of my Viennese
dear Mozart to which the repost this
time was well, let them chew on it
a while. They'll get used to it.
Um, and they did and getting used
to it. But unfortunately, uh,
by time Mozart was dead. Um,
so he didn't, he didn't, uh,
live actually to see the success of,
of his particular vision.
So, uh, with Mozart, there is this
sense of music that is divinely, uh,
shape, divinely proportion,
sort of endless variety,
not one the note too many,
not one note too few.
And indeed in his day,
Mozart Bruce referred
to as the divine Mozart.
We still call them the divine Mojo.
It's interesting what labels
get put on particular composers.
Bach for example,
I'm not sure we'd call Bach divine.
We have the stalwart Bach, the
Industria in industrial, uh,
industrious Bach, for example,
Beethoven, the powerful Bach, the stripe,
the powerful composure, the
striving composer, uh, uh,
I can sort of relate to Bach in a way
with his 20 children or with Beethoven in
the chaos. You look at a Beethoven score
and it's this train wreck. You know,
these scribbled here, we're trying
to correct this and wrote this out.
And then he has his dinner falls
over top of the manuscript.
So he's got to sweep that away. It's just
his whole life kind of chaotic there.
But with most artists,
all sort of crystal clear and crisp,
perfectly organized almost
from the get go in these, uh,
autograph scores.
And that's what we mean sort of by the,
the divine nature of, of the music, uh,
sort of heavenly scent music.
It's an interesting phenomena.
This idea of art and religion
and, and, and why we have,
um, have these kinds of things. Um,
I often think of myself, I'm
not a particularly religious
person, but, but I, I,
I am one of these people that kind of
take a art and turn it into religion in a
kind of odd kind of way.
And I think it is possible to see
visions of the divine working with,
with art. And occasionally I
do get this and in an odd way,
this isn't this what art is
supposed to all be about.
I mean, why do we have art?
What does it do for us?
It gives us a sense of something better,
a vision of something better than this
stupid mundane in the vernacular crap
that we have to deal with on a,
on the quo DTN basis out here.
There could be something better.
There's something bigger and
better out there than we are.
That in essence is what what are is all
about. And sometimes you can see it and,
and I think you can see it or you should
seem to be getting near to it. Well,
one of the experiences my life standing
at the west end of the Cathedral Shark
on a bright sunny day when
the, the backend of the
church is still cold and dark.
But all of these beautiful blue light
streaming through streaming through the
stained glass in music,
it often happens sometimes maybe with
Gustaf Moller but Patrik particularly with
Mozart, particularly with Mozart.
And I think it has to do with the,
the sense of,
of balance and crystalline clarity,
uh,
that's operating there.
So that's what you get with most
started crystalline clarity,
balance and performance, uh,
balancing and proportion.
And sometimes with Mozart You
get vision of Hell as well.
When he switches off into to the minors.
So it's a,
it's a kind of total cosmos.
And I was struck recently, uh,
when I came across a
passage of Yohanis Kepler.
Now don't get me wrong here,
I don't sit around reading the
astrophysicists. Yohanas Kepler,
I was reading something
else and this happened,
that crop up as quote
from Kepler came up in it.
How many of you in your physics courses,
they mentioned Kepler at all? All right.
So, you know, you guys know kept her
a lot better than I do. Let's not,
let's not put on airs here,
but this is what a Kepler said.
Uh, and it seemed like a really
good passage to me. All right?
He's talking about music
here and humanity, man,
the ape of his creator has discovered the
art of music so that he might play the
everlasting,
this of all created time in some short
part of an hour by means of an artistic
Concorde of many voices and instruments
that he might to some extent tastes the
satisfaction of God,
the workman through music,
God, the workman through
music. Interesting idea.
Now in the same, same vein.
However, what does music,
what does art do for us?
I was struck there in the
country music hall of fame, uh,
on Saturday in which, um, the, you know,
you go into these things is rock and
roll hall and you push a button and then
the one of these artists will
come and talk to you or you know,
the recorded thing there or
sometimes they'll play music.
Well they had African American country
singer Charley Pride there. Um,
and he had something to say, ah, I
didn't get it down exactly, you know,
verbatim. But this is the gist of
it. I went back and wrote it down.
This is what Charlie pride had to say.
Music is a bridge to my
dis distant memories.
When I hear a piece,
it reminds me of a time or an event of
my childhood or my youth music carries me
back.
There.
It is a line that links me into
the deep reservoir of my memory.
So that, that I think is also true.
That's another thing that music does for,
had called.
And I bet you've experienced this too.
So pristine and the way you hear,
you hear something that reminds you when
you first heard that piece or what you
were doing or perhaps a person
or an environment. So those are,
those are the two advantages of, of
music. There are others you can dance to,
which I can relax you, et
Cetera, et cetera. But,
but this idea of tapping into who you are,
you the whole who you are as a person
through a getting you back in touch with
your inner memories and
also perhaps giving you hope
that there is something out
there better than what we deal
with on a daily basis. Um,
these are two important aspects
of music in it. Interesting.
That one would come from
the astrophysicists,
Kepler and the other from the
country music singer, Charley Pride.
But that's one of the wonders of the
diversity of, of music I suppose.
Um,
okay.
Well we don't guarantee you hear any
kind of divine experience as part of
signing up for music.
One 12,
the divine transcendental experience
is not an entitlement here.
We don't guarantee it. But you may
have years at some point in your life.
And I suspect it will come in
some way in association with art,
whether the visual arts,
architecture and music, whatever. Uh,
and it may come in music
with music of Mozart,
but how can you sort
of load the dice here?
How can you get things in your favor?
How could you put yourself,
you know, success in life is
positioning. Your CSA is lucky. Well,
you put yourself there
to be, to be lucky. Uh,
how can you get in a position
to have this experience?
We'll take a look at the sheet. I sit
as sitting there last night, uh, typing,
typing this up, seeing him, and we
used to put these lists on the board,
but then the list got so long.
I just started to just to put them on a
sheet for today. Uh, so here's the list.
Okay.
Craig's essential Mozart if you will,
a piano concertos.
Mozart's sort of invented
the piano concerto.
We're going to watch a concerto
shortly, uh, in, um, in music, uh,
in section.
I'm going to just recommend this to you.
I see we have our performers here.
We're going to go on now.
We'll end up here a little bit with
some, uh, talking about opera here.
You can read through this. Mozart wrote
three great operas, a marriage of Figaro,
Don Giovanni, uh, the magic flute.
And we're now going to segue over
to, uh, the discussion of opera.
Uh, what's opera musically?
Heightened drama.
Music is there behind the
drama and it reinforces it.
It does the same thing in film.
Ever. Think about horror films.
What's The scariest horror
film you've ever seen?
A J Chucky.
Okay. There's, there's one
I don't know about that. Uh,
shining, something like that.
I don't know.
Think of something.
I don't get scared when watching
a movie until what happens.
I see some really scary
visual. Come on. What,
what scares you in movies? So
posting, they took the sound,
the sound track out of these horror films,
you wouldn't be frightened at all.
It's w I think we have a much
more visceral response to sound.
And we do two visual images and that's
what's going on globally in opera.
And opera, as you know, is made
up of an introductory overture.
And then these numbers such as recitatives
where the composer tells you what's
going on. You remember the,
the bugs bunny cartoons,
I guess it's Warner brothers
cartoon. Be Very quiet. Hi,
I'm hunting. Why bit that
kind of thing, you know,
so that's a rested to teeth.
What's, what's going on. Um,
then somebody will come out and sing
about how they felt about what just
happened. That's what goes
on in an Aria. And Ari is,
we'll tend to repeat words and,
and on and on.
It goes to give a sense of emotion and
their choruses involved in it from time
to time too. As we mentioned, Mozart
wrote three, um, wonderful operas,
two of them by the librettist Lorenzo
de Ponti read in Your Textbook.
There's a box on Lorenzo dupont. It
absolutely fascinating life, far,
far more fascinating than
fiction could ever make it.
But we're going to talk
now about Don Giovanni.
Uh, what music is this? Linda? Can
we have the next piece of music?
[inaudible]
okay.
what's that? Nice and loud.
Somebody got it out there.
Overture to Don Giovanni overture.
Don Giovanni.
You headed the basis of your listening
exercise 25 and Sonata Allegro form.
But it's a different side of Mozart,
different sides of Mozart.
This is the demonic demonic Mozart.
It's the story of a Ma as kind of a rake,
misogynist,
a woman hater who tries to seduce every
woman that comes into view simply for
the sadistic pleasure of doing so.
So that's the basis of this.
It's an interesting
time in the history of,
of intellectual processes and
political process is to here we have,
uh, uh, a story that involves male,
female that don't, don't be distracted
because this is one of our cast members.
It's about to come up with the dog and
he's bringing Richard along with him. No,
no, don't go away. Um, so, uh,
we have this conflict between
male and female interests.
We also have the social being played
out here because we have the high class
nobleman who goes around disguised and,
and seducing women as the villain.
And the noble people here are actually
the peasants and servants who are doing
his bidding. So that's the kind of of
tension that exists here in Don Giovanni.
And note the year up there
on the board. 17 uh, what's,
I guess it's on your
sheet for Don Giovanni,
right down there at the bottom 1788
the year before the French revolution.
Okay. Richard, if you would join
me please, that would be great.
We have a guest with us today and we're
going to introduce him. Richard Lawley,
how many of you know who Richard Lolly
is? Okay. Oh God, the famous guy already.
Um,
Richard is a professor of music here at
Yale and what really annoys me is that a
year or so ago,
he won the single most important
prize at Yale University.
And what is it the prize for the
best teacher at Yale? How many uh,
undergraduate instructors do?
We have here? Four, five, 600,
numero uno over there. Uh, but
more equally interesting. Um,
he is also what,
hmm,
incoming master of Jonathan Edwards
college starting for next semester,
starting in January.
And he happens to be a darn good singer,
as you will see here in just a minute.
So we're going to start out here
with a little of this. And, uh,
Richard and his friend are going
to help us out here. Hi there.
Um, and did, uh, okay. So,
uh, so, uh, Jacob come on up. All
we've got here is an Aria first for,
um, Leparello who's The servant of
Don Giovanni. He's a kind of, of,
had low on the academic totem pole.
He's kind of like a ta in life here.
So we've called on,
we've called on Jacob,
we've called on Jacob. Oh,
there he is. Okay. So this is
Leparello and as you'll notice,
Mozart crafts the music to fit Leparello.
It's not high falutin music.
It has a rather narrow range.
It doesn't go with,
it has a lot of pattern respite to
in Vinod. And at the very beginning,
Mozart kind of blocks
out this pacing idea.
Leparello is down underneath a balcony.
Don Giovanni is up above
trying to seduce Dona Ana, um,
and he's impatient and he hates this
position in life in which he has been put
running errands.
Nice.
Yeah.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
And thanks to Santana also
who learned this part in one
day, basically, right? Yup.
All right, so things have not gone
well this time unexpectedly. Uh,
Ana has been able to rebuff Don Giovanni
and she now wants to unmask him and she
would then find out that he's really the
leading noble men of the town wants to
unmask him. She chases him after him
out of the p runs away, she's screaming,
she calls for her father,
uh,
who is the aging commendatory
and the commendatory, excuse me,
they come into Toray, um,
confronts Don Giovanni,
uh,
tries to challenge him to a duel
and they engage in such a duel.
So let's,
uh,
we'll have don Giovanni come up and
let me grab the commendatory music.
Oh, don't touch that. Commendatory
music. Great. Here we go. Thanks.
Yeah,
so I have, um, Richard,
I'm told that they would like us to
be sort of out here. Okay. All right.
So, uh, here comes the commendatory.
Here comes the minor music and we're
going to have a confrontation between the
commendatory,
the old commander and the
youthful spry vocally,
uh,
skillful Don Giovanni.
Well,
here's the bill
fights with bald head.
Oh,
word
tried
hard head
meeting hall.
Oh,
you
is.
All right,
we cut that.
Yeah.
So then there is a little dining
scene and if I were blocking this,
I would have don Giovanni,
something like this,
having just been stabbed. Okay. Excuse me.
The commendatory would
just be stabbed like this.
Don Giovanni was over top of him.
Roadside Mozart wrote this exquisite
little trio here. He goes by very quickly,
nobody ever noticed it.
But if some of the most beautiful
music that he ever wrote, um,
we ended up on the diminished chord and
then Santana plays a diminished chord
again at the top of that line
where he gets stabbed. Yep.
MMM.
Okay. And then we had this little
trio Leparello are you back there?
Leparello okay. Uh, he is just cowering.
He just wants to get out and he
just wants to get out of here.
This is the worst thing he's ever seen.
Don Giovanni's a bit surprised,
but he says you had coming to in the
commendatory is about to, to, uh,
buy the farm here. He's on his way out. So
it's just this little, bro, I don't know,
10 12 measures are so of
exquisitely beautiful music.
And we'll do it nice and slowly for you
dead,
my child.
Oh
No.
Okay.
So that's that scene
and on to the next, and we have,
we'll run over a minute or two,
but it'll be well worth it.
Uh,
Don Giovanni goes onto another seduction
in which he attempts to engage,
uh, in an amorous compromise. The
peasant girl is there, Lena, uh,
they engage in a little bit of
recitatives. He makes his advanced.
She is initially intrigued.
Will she
succumb to his advances?
Let's find out
afraid of fortune.
I hear too often how,
you know, the mentoring
slanderous ravings of the Mbse
all night.
Not both has an honesty native
to his blue. He not afraid
to. Fortunately, we'll be married today.
No longer.
Yeah.
Amen.
No,
that's fine.
Too
small.
Calm to me or no
on?
No, no, I'm good.
Why not?
Hi.
That's all.
Hello.
Oh,
no.
Ooh.
Hello.
That's it for today. Next week.
We're doing during the demo room.